الينا من عمان مراسله صباح العربيه سهى
جميل سها كانت حاضره للحفل ابرز مشاهداتك
وما الذي رايتيه وايد كثير اسئله عندنا يا
سهى قولي لنا القصه
صباح الخير عادل وراويه طبعا انا تشرفت
بحضور هذا الحفل مادوبات العشاء من قبل
الملكه رانيا العبد الله وحفل الحناء
بدايه دعني اقول ان الحضور المباشر لهذا
الحفل يختلف كثيرا عن حضوره على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي ومتم بث من مقاطع
اختزلت الكثير من المشاهد ربما دعني اقول
ان العائله الهاشميه معروفه ببساطتها لم
يكن هناك اجواء مختلفه عن الاردنيين او عن
الحضور الذين دعتهم جلاله الملكه كانت
تلامس كل اردني اطياف الاردنيين جميعا
الحضور كانوا يشعرون بان هذا الحفل يمس كل
اردني البساطه الهاشميه المعتاده كانت
موجوده الالوان التي تبهج القلب حضور
الملكه رانيا والاميره رجوى ربما كان
الشعور يعني شعور ام اتجاه ابنتها لم يكن
هناك شيء بعيد
هذا هو قصر زهران هذا من اقدم القصور
واعرقها هذا قصر زهران الذي سيتم به عقد
القران ولكن حفل الحناء كان في بيت العز
الديوان الملكي الهاشمي قصر رغدان هذا
القصر الذي سيتم به عقد القران والذي ايضا
تم عقد قران جلاله الملك عبد الله الثاني
والملك الراحل الحسين بن طلال من هنا
سيخرج الموكب الاحمر في حفل الزفاف في
اليوم الاول من بدايه الشهر المقبل هذا
القصر الذي شهد افراح العديد من الهاشميين
لاحظنا كمان حتى من الفيديوهات التي تم
نشرها حتى في الزغاريد وبالاغاني
وبكل يعني مقتطفات الحفل كان هناك حضور
ايضا للثقافه السعوديه بما انه طبعا
العروسه السعوديه حتى في الزغاريد سمعت
زغروطه حلوه كثير لبست الفستان طيه على طي
طي اردنيه وطي سعوديه
حطينا عن هذا الجانب هذا الخليط الجميل من
الثقافي الجميل ايضا رجاء
مني نعم بما ان الثقافه السعوديه والاغاني
ليست بعيده عن الثقافه الاردنيه كان هذا
يبهج القلب كثيرا كان هذا يعني تترنم عليه
الاذان لم يكن هناك شيء بعيد عن ثقافتنا
الاردنيه او حتى عن ثقافتنا السعوديه كانت
الاغاني بسيطه نسمعها في العديد من حفلات
الحناء لم يكن هناك شيء يعني بعيد او او
شيء فوق العادي كان بسيط ولكنه راويه كان
انيق لو حضرتي الاحتفال هناك شيء ساحر لا
يمكن نسيانه يلامس القلب لم يكن هناك بعد
عن الحضور الحضور شعر بكل كلمه بكل اغنيه
حتى ان الاغاني يعني كانت اغاني دخلت بيت
عمها يعني يعني تحدث المواطن الاردني ان
فعلا الكنه هي تدخل من يسمى الاب والام اب
العريس وام العروس هم العم والعمه وبذلك
شعرنا فعلا اننا نحضر يعني عرس قريب لنا
وشعرنا بفرحه هي كانت فرحه كبيره ولكن
الفرحه اكثر كيف
الملكه رانيا لان تشاركنا هي هذه الفرحه
وقالت ايضا ان هذه فرحتنا نحن فرحه الشعب
الاردني والشعب السعودي
شكرا جزيلا سهى جميل مراسله صباح العربيه
من عمان شكرا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات